the tour down under for us really
differs from other tours primarily
because it's the first race of the
season so riders come into in different
physical shapes if you like it's the
first race of the year and everyone's
come out of a long offseason and it kind
of got a point to prove going into the
new year and go into it you know quite a
few guys going to organs blazing from a
nutritional perspective is the
temperature and that poses a real
considerable challenge because it's the
first race of the season then many many
riders come in not really picked
acclimatize so you have to try and work
hard to try and reduce the stress at the
heat stress to hopefully make sure that
we perform well in that particular risk
yeah we have like a heat protocol that
we run across all of our races once it
gets to a certain temperature so as soon
as we know that temperature is going to
be reached which it will be in torreón
though it sort of we set off a chain of
events that they do and it's mainly
around the care is in the team you know
with the hydration side year by year
dealt with it better and better as you
get older and a bit more mature as a
bike rider you tend to cope with the
difficulties a little bit easier but
then yeah first year I went now on the
Sterling stage I completely like wiped
out I was Oh seeing stars you know and
then it's yes quite dangerous at times
you see some people in the right mess
but hopefully now got to the point where
I can you know race and 40 degrees and
still it's the will to perform to a half
decent level so the riders hydration
strategies are on a hot riya slated to
die namba would involve a lot more
electrolytes so we would use our science
and sport drinks that have added
electrolytes and we will try and advise
that perhaps a drink to thirst strategy
which for us usually a quiz to at least
five hundred mils per hour on the bike
you know we got the best products to
support the best we can
and just using the right things at the
right time I think electro likes to
obviously key so being able to take them
on bike through the gels I think it's
the easiest way to get them in the
system and of course heat stress
increases carbohydrate use so last but
not least is we have to make sure that
riders are actually consuming the
required amounts of carbohydrate when
they're on the bike we aiming for at
least 60 to 90 grams of carbohydrate for
our it's the balance between
carbohydrate as the balance between
hydration and if we get that correct
then hopefully we will perform well so
one of the simplest strategies to
monitor of people are actually hydrated
correctly is of course to weigh them we
wear them every morning during this the
risk we weigh them before the race
itself and we wear them after the risk
and if you do that well and you do that
consistently then you can very closely
pick out real trends if people are over
hydrating or under hydrating and
essentially they're on track really to
immunity in the performance
you